en capitaine au capitaine ainsi
l'évolution des sols robin williams
avait ébranlé plusieurs cinéphiles dans
le film culte la société des poètes
disparus
sorti il ya 30 ans cette scène et passe
à l'histoire
on l'attend exprime ce sentiment disant
carte pétillaient qui en connaît la
signification
le texte a été récemment adapté au
théâtre par le scénariste du film qui
reprend fidèlement l'histoire originale
campé en 1959 dans une école de garçons
c'est patrice dubois qui interprète le
coloré professeur keating qui pousse
avec conviction ses élèves à devenir de
libres penseurs romantique
ayvaz loin il va loin mais je pense
qu'il va profondément avec il va où il
veut aller toucher le meilleur d'eux
mêmes les enseignements du professeur
keating à vivre ses rêves et à défier
les aspirations parentale ont changé la
vie de plusieurs personnes dont celle du
metteur en scène qui a vu le film à
l'âge de 12 ans moi j'ai pris le chemin
le moins fréquenté je me suis engagé
dans le fond écouter keating j'ai choisi
le théâtre alors que mes parent devait
ce nouveau à risque et alors qu'un jour
aujourd'hui j'ai envie donc si je
n'avais pas écouté quitter je répète une
job je serai peut-être malheureux qui le
je fais ce que j'aime aujourd'hui
signe que le sujet est encore actuelle
il ya eu une ovation bien sentie de la
part des 800 élèves du secondaire venus
assister à la toute première
représentation
je pense que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
ils voyaient pas cette chose comme ça
que la vis il faut en prendre soin puis
que tout peut arriver
il faut pas lâcher c'est ce que les
jeunes veulent voir je pense qu'ils ont
besoin de sentir que des gens qui ont
des adultes qui les mp3 à l'ère des
réseaux sociaux
la société des poètes disparus est une
invitation à ne pas suivre le troupeau
est à saisir l'occasion de mener une vie
authentique à notre véritable image
oui
un vieux ici louis fait dépouiller mais
radio-canada mourir
je le démens qui paie ce solde est
supportable